Today.
I'm going to start with two different stories
about challengers to Joe Biden and Donald
Trump, respectively, in their 2024 primaries
for Joe Biden.
The Democratic primary for Donald Trump, The
Republican primary.
We're going to start with some really interesting
clips from an interview that Fox News propagandist
did last night with bobby kennedy jr.
Robert f Kennedy Jr, who's running as a Democrat
in the Democratic primary challenging joe
Biden.
Now, I don't know whether I need to rehash
my overall view about challengers to incumbent
presidents running for reelection, But to
be 100% clear, I support challenges to incumbent
presidents.
Joe Biden doesn't have any particular claim
to the Democratic nomination just because
he's an incumbent.
Anybody who wants to run against him should.
I would like to see debates.
I get why the DNC isn't going to do them,
because why would you ever put your current
president from your party in a position where
they can really only damage themselves?
And I understand why the DNC isn't going to
do debates.
It's not unique to the Democratic Party.
It's not unique to Joe Biden.
It's not unique to 2024.
That being said, the current challengers to
Joe Biden, Bobby Kennedy Jr and Marianne Will
Williamson are not particularly impressive
to me.
Now, before we get to the interview, you have
to understand something really specific that's
going on with right wing media and the people
challenging Biden right now, meaning Bobby
Kennedy Jr and Marianne Williamson.
Marianne Williamson was also interviewed by
HANNITY last night.
We're not going to look at that interview
today, but maybe we will later in the week.
And one of the things you have to understand
is that Kennedy and Marianne Williamson are
useful to right wing media as ways to criticize
Joe Biden and to criticize the Democratic
Party.
They don't actually find these candidacies
interesting on their merits.
The Bobby Kennedy one is interesting because
it's an Anti-vaxx candidacy.
So that might be one way in which it is interesting.
But when HANNITY interviews Marianne Williamson,
if you look at that interview, there was a
whole bunch of focus on Moore five or six
times, trying to get Marianne Williamson to
say she believes Joe Biden is suffering from
severe cognitive decline.
It's not because HANNITY thinks Marianne's
platform is valuable, that he's having her
on.
He's having her on to try to get her to attack
Biden on something he wants to see Biden attacked
on and similar.
Similarly with Bobby Kennedy jr.
It's not that the anti-vax actually is interesting,
but it's just another way to criticize Democrats
and to attack the DNC.
Okay.
So that's the context of why these right wing
shows are interviewing people like Bobby Kennedy
Jr and Marianne Williamson.
That all being said, Sean HANNITY asked Bobby
Kennedy Jr.
Since you're an environmentalist, are you
swearing off private jet travel?
And Bobby Kennedy Jr fails hard.
This is an example of what happens when you're
totally unprepared.
Bobby says, And again, remember, Bobby's a
nice guy.
I had dinner with him once.
We have many friends in common.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba.
But I think the candidacy is ridiculous.
I think his anti-vaxx activism is ridiculous.
He first says he is not someone who regularly
flies on private jets or he kind of is like,
I don't fly on the much.
Totally unprepared.
And this just looks terribly.
This is looks terribly.
Look at this.
You are getting on a private jet.
Have you given up all use of private jets
I of your environmental views.
I was literally laughing out loud when I saw
this this morning.
Are you really going to act on?
I'm not really.
That's a simple question.
Yes.
Did you.
Are you pledging to never do?
Have you given up the use of private jets?
John.
I don't fly on private jets.
I don't regularly fly on private jets.
I don't regularly fly on private.
Oh, okay.
Breaking up any use of somebody is there?
Yeah.
Listen, I've never objected to people flying.
Listen, I think this climate alarmist stuff
is a bunch of crap, so I don't care if you
do or not, but if you're claiming to be a
big environmentalist, you shouldn't be flying
on a private jet, right?
I'm not.
Oh, that's.
I'm not that kind of environmentalist.
I, i, i he's a private jet environmentalist.
Guys I have been fighting for.
Against pollution on the rivers and water,
against pollution, against carbon pollution
because of the toxicity of those things.
I have not told people that they shouldn't
fly on private jets.
Okay.
This is really bad, guys.
This is also so stupid, because, listen, private
Jet, I mean, all jet, the harvesting, refining
and burning of jet fuel pollutes rivers.
You know, he's acting like now I focus on,
like DuPont leaking chemicals into a river
or rivers.
Well, okay.
What do you think happens with the production
and the burning of jet fuel all over the country?
Gets some of it gets into rivers?
This is just it's not serious.
This is not this is none of this is serious.
This is embarrassing and humiliating.
And it is a gotcha from Sean HANNITY.
It is a gotcha from Sean HANNITY.
But it's one that you've got to be prepared
for.
You really have to be prepared for it.
There was another moment I want to look at
here where and remember, Bobby Kennedy's Democratic
campaign is one that is extraordinarily pro-Putin,
It's conspiratorial, it's anti-vax.
It's a lot of things that that the kind of
do I want to call it the regressive left likes.
We'll get to that in a moment.
He brings up a totally unfounded conspiracy
theory about what's going on in Ukraine.
And by the way, what we're doing in Ukraine
is not good for the Ukrainian people.
We have killed 300,000 Ukrainian troops or
10,000 civilians.
Well, Europe Europe has stepped up.
We have not killed any Ukrainian troops.
I'm trying to think what on earth is he talking
about?
What could he mean?
We've killed 300,000 Ukrainian troops.
Russia has maybe I don't know if that's even
the number.
Russia has killed Ukrainian troops, but only
if you interpret this to mean that we, the
U.S., caused induced or forced Russia to invade
Ukraine.
Could you say we have anything to do with
the killing of Ukrainian troops?
So this is really bonkers stuff, just the
chaos agent per Steve Bannon.
Right.
To use a Steve Bannon term.
This is a chaos agent.
And my colleague John sent me this article
this morning from the New Republic.
The article is called Who Are These Supposed
Lefties Who Love Robert F Kennedy Jr.
And if you read the article and if you just
look around online, you very quickly realize
that even though he's nominally running as
a Democrat, Bobby Kennedy Jr is running a
sort of combination pro-Putin anti-U.S. sort
of campaign.
It's appealing to those folks who are often
in league with people like Bashar al Assad
and Vladimir Putin and the Maduro Chavez regime
of Venezuela.
And then it's also people who dabble in anti-vax,
people who dabble in anti-science conspiracy
theorists, opportunists, etc..
It's certainly not a progressive campaign.
And to even call it a Democratic leaning campaign
doesn't really make sense.
So that's what's going on on the Democratic
side, people challenging Joe Biden and again,
I say challenge him, bring everybody in.
Everybody should run, run against him.
Okay.
But that doesn't mean I have to celebrate
and welcome every individual campaign.
Let's now talk briefly about the side challenging
Donald Trump.